i think some people are not
loving seeing
um these characters maybe off-kilter
cynthia nixon is fully aware that not
all sex and the city fans are digging
miranda's storyline on the hbo max
revival series and just like that but
personally the 55 year old actress is
loving it we came back to
to throw these characters into new
situations and let them
you know follow their hearts you didn't
like us because we were boring the first
time you liked us because we took
chances and that's what we're doing just
to get you up to speed miranda had an
affair with carrie's co-worker che who
identifies as non-binary there's
definitely a lot to take in between
these two and the possibilities are
endless in order to be with jay miranda
had to do this
is this really happening are you asking
me for a divorce
this is really happening and when
cynthia stopped by the drew barrymore
show on wednesday she addressed all the
haters characterizing miranda's sexual
awakening as a midlife crisis
you reach a moment you know you can when
you put a negative spin on it you can
call it like a mid-life crisis right but
out of crises come really productive
things and it's like
you're you're not young anymore but
you're not old either and you still have
time to like make sure that your life is
the way you want it to be and if you're
deeply unhappy in your career choices
and you're you're really deeply unhappy
in your marriage you should look at it
and demand more all that echoes what
cynthia told e.t back in december we're
not trying to pretend that we're younger
than we are we're 55 and that doesn't
mean that there shouldn't be a show
about these characters it's a moment in
in women's lives where they often do
kind of reevaluate where they are
there's more
behind me than there is left but i'm
still plenty young enough that i could
actually embark on a whole new adventure
and cynthia says that she was actually
the one to suggest sarah ramirez play
che i've been aware of them for so long
and such a fan i was always watching
their career and stuff this character is
dynamic this character is smart funny
witty
very human very messy and very confident
it's really wonderful that we have the
first non-binary series regular
character in the universe of sex and the
city it's been a real thrill and an
honor to be invited in as for the die
hard steve fans who are reeling after
miranda dropped the divorce bomb well
cynthia responded to all that during a
stop by late night with seth meyers
steve's not having a great time in the
news
he's not yeah
you know i love steve i love steve too
i feel like i don't know why you guys
did them like that oh
i think it was very bold we're not going
to be treading water we're actually
going to be sailing into completely
unchartered waters the season finale of
and just like that will air february 3rd
but fans are already wondering will
there be a season two i am not a writer
and so that is one of the great
privileges of not being a writer is it's
not my job to figure it out but in terms
of the the amazing writers that we have
dreaming things up
they know much better than